مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض وهذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
مصادر دبلوماسيه تكشف للعربيه عن توصل
الاطراف السودانيه لاتفاق مبدئي خلال
محادثات جدا
الجوازات السعوديه تمدد اقامه تاشيرات
المعتمرين السودانيين وتطلق خدمه
الاستضافه
هيئه الصناعات العسكريه السعوديه تعلن عن
تجاوز نسبه توطين القطاع الثلاثه عشر في
المئه
ومن ملفاتنا المتنوعه في الرابعه كذلك
الجمارك السعوديه تعلن احباط محاوله تهريب
نحو نصف مليون حبه مخدره عبر منفذ الحديث
وزاره البيئه السعوديه تعلن عن اتفاقيه
لشراء خمس طائرات لاستمطار السحب ودراسات
المناخ
حياكم الله قالت مصادر من الجيش السوداني
انه تم اطلاق المرحله
وذلك بعد السيطره على جسر
اكد المصدر ان الجيش السوداني يتمكن من
طرد مجموعات الدعم السريع من مناطق شرق
الخرطوم بحري
وفي حوار لعضو مجلس سياده الحاكم في
السودان الفريق ياسر العطا مع الشرق
الاوسط اكد الفريق العطاء ان الجيش يسيطر
على كافه الولايات السودانيه ما عدا بعض
المناطق التي تنتشر فيها عناصر من الدعم
السريع كما ابعد الجيش الدعم السريع من
محيط القياده العامه ومطار الخرطوم رغم
استهدافها بالمدفعيه من مسافات بعيده فيما
تبقت معركه القصر الجمهوري التي فرض فيها
الجيش الحصار على الدعم السريع للقضاء
عليهم اوضح الفريق ياسر العطاء ان مجموعه
فاجنر الروسيه تقاتل في السودان وان الجيش
السوداني قتل احد عناصرها وشدد العطاء على
ان قائد الدعم السريع تهمه الخيانه العظمى
وسيتم تجريده من القابه
ومن ام درمان ينضم الينا الصحفي مقداد حسن
مقداد مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض بدايه ما هي التفاصيل اطلاق الجيش
السوداني لهذه المرحله المرحله الاخيره
للسيطره على خرطوم بحري واهم المناطق
الحيويه كذلك فيها
نعم باعتبار ان الجيش في الليل السابقه او
في يوم امس يعني شن هجوما عنيفا على مقر
وتمركزات وتوزعات قوات الدعم السريع في
منطقه الخرطوم بحري كان اليوم يعني شديدا
وعنيفا جدا مقارنه بما يحدث اليوم في جميع
انحاء العاصمه المثلثه اليوم الاشتباكات
والغارات الجويه كانت اقل عنفا مقارنه بما
كان بالامس
وبعض المناوشات هنا وهناك في مدينه بحري
تحديدا وشرق النيل حي الحلفايه وكذلك حي
الشنبات شهد غارات جويه بدايه هذا الصباح
ومنتصف النهار وطائرات الاستطلاع يعني
خففت
جولاتها
واستطلاعاتها في سماء الخرطوم وسط الخرطوم
ايضا كان اقل هدوءا مقارنه مع الايام
السابقه ومدينه ام درمان
على اختلاف المدن الثلاثه ايضا تشهد يعني
هدوءا نسبيا وحذرا وترقبا لما قد تسفره
الساعات القادمه وربما نحن نتحدث عن
مفاوضات تفضي الى اتفاق اولي او مبدئي طيب
بحسب المصادر الدبلوماسيه ويمكن ان يفسر
او يقرا ذلك على انها بدات التهدئه على
الارض بشكل نسبي اين كانت تتموضع قوه
الدعم السريع في الخرطوم بحري تحديدا
والتي استهدفها طيران الجيش او التي يعني
كما قال في بيانه بانه طردهم ايضا من هذه
المعسكرات التابعه لهم
اغلب اغلب المعارك التي دارت بين قوات
الجيش السوداني القوات المسلحه والدعم
السريع كانت في مدينه بحري تحديدا في
منطقه حي الشمبات والحلفايه حي الحلفايه
حتى لحظات قريبه يشهد مناوشات بسيطه هنا
وهناك وكذلك الغارات الجويه كانت في هذا
الحي وايضا بحسب المصادر ان هنالك استهداف
لمقار في شرق النيل ومنطقه بحري منطقه
كبيره جدا فيها تموضوعات لقوات الدعم
السريع تحديدا فيها في جسر شنبات الذي
يحتوي على معسكر في الناحيه الشرقيه في
الناحيه الشرقيه لمدينه ام درمان وبالتالي
فان قوات الدعم السريع تتموضع في اماكن
واسعه جدا على
نطاق مدينه بحري
الطيران والقوات البريه والمدفعيه تحاول
في في غارات جويه ومعارك عنيفه جدا ان
تتقدم في مواقع في مواطن مختلفه وهذا ما
تفسره الطلعات الجويه العنيفه التي شهدها
ليله الامس عطفا على بيان الجيش السوداني
ايضا ماذا عن العاصمه الخرطوم المفاصل
الرئيسيه المهمه فيها عن المطار عن القصر
الجمهوري عن كذلك ايضا مبنى القياده
العامه للقوات المسلحه هل سيطر عليها
الجيش او امتلك فيها زمام الامور بشكل
كامل وحاسم مقداد
نعم بحسب المصادر لدينا التي يعني قالت ان
هنالك معارك خفيف
خفيفه جدا خفيفه جدا في في وسط العاصمه
الخرطوم وبحسب بيان الجيش فانه يؤكد على
يعني
تقدمه في محيط في محيط القياده العامه وان
المعركه حاليا اصبحت هي معركه القصر
الجمهوري وبالتالي فان الجميع هنا يترقب
ما ستسفيره الساعات القادمه في المعارك
المحتدمه بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني اشكرك جزيل الشكر من ام درمان
كانضم الي الصحه في مقداد حسن شكري مقداد
شدد مفاوض الامم المتحده لحقوق الانسان
فولكر تورك على اهميه التزام طرفي الزراعي
في السودان وبشكل عاجل بعمليه سياسيه
شامله والتفاوض حول السلام واكد ثور خلال
جلسه خاصه حول الوضع في السودان ان الطرفي
النزاع انتهك القانون الانساني الدولي
داعيا جميع الدول ذات النفوذ في المنطقه
الى التشجيع على حل للازمه بكل سبل
الممكنه
وبشان المحادثات التي تجري في جده بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع بوساطه
سعوديه امريكيه كشفت مصادر الدبلوماسيه
للعربيه انه سيتم التوقيع على اتفاق مبادئ
اولي يتحدث عن قبول الهدنه للدواعى
الانسانيه فقط على ان تستكمل المباحثات
عبر الوساطه السعوديه الامريكيه في مرحله
ثانيه لاحقا ولم يتم تحديد موعد التوقيع
المرتقب بالاتفاق ببنود ما زال النقاش
حولها مستمرا واضافت مصادر العربيه للجيش
وكذلك الدعم السريع طرح بعض المطالب
والاشتراطات الا ان الوساطه راى التاجيلها
لحصر الاتفاق على وقف اطلاق النار وفتح
ممرات امنه لايصال المساعدات الانسانيه
ومن مدينه ابها ينضم الينا استاذ الاعلام
في جامعه الملك خالد الدكتور عوض ابراهيم
عوض دكتور ابراهيم مساء الخير مرحبا بك
معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض بدايه
دكتور كيف يمكن النظر لهذه الخطوه خطوه
التوقيع
اتفاق اولي او اتفاق مبدئي لطرفي الازمه
السودانيه في جده كيف يمكن بناء عليه كذلك
يا هلا بك لايف
واحيي مشاهدي قناه العربيه
في الواقع الاتفاق الذي يعني بدا منذ ايام
في مدينه جده برعايه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
انظار كل السودانيين الذين يعملون منه
الكثير لانهاء هذه الحرب التي اندلعت بين
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني ممثل لحكومه
السودان ولدوله السودان
ومنذ الايام الماضيه كان الناس يعني
يتحسسون ما يتسرب من هذا الاجتماع المهم
جدا
واعتقد انه الوصول الى
قضايا مبدئيه توقع في هذه المرحله
امر مهم جدا لا سيما وان القضيه معقده
لابعد ابعد الحدود
طرف الجيش السوداني طبعا وهو يبدو انه قد
هيمنه بشكل اكبر على ساحات المعارك في
السودان
لا يريد ان يتخلص من هذه المعمعه الا وقد
بسط سيطرته على كل مواقع
المتمردين
ويستطيع ان يقول بعد ذلك انه قد انهى
المعركه على المستوى العسكري
رجال الدعم السريع
رغما على الظروف التي يعايشونها والتشتت
الذي حدث لهم لديهم كان الامل في ان
يحققوا نصرا ولو قليلا ولذلك تمسكوا جدا
بالقصر الجمهوري وتمسكوا بمطار الخرطوم
وتمسكوا بالقياده العامه لفتره طويله طبعا
في الاصل هم كانوا فيها يعني لم يحتلوها
اثناء المعركه طيب لما شعروا بالحكايه
طبعا دخلوا على البيوت فبالتالي الان
الاتفاق انا اعتقد مهم جدا في هذه المرحله
ولا نطمع في اكثر مما توصل اليه الان
المتحدث ما الذي يعني يمكن ان يطمع به
السودانيون في القمه العربيه القادمه في
الرياض ما الذي يمكن ان يعولوا عليه
لمعالجه انسانيه على الاقل للوضع السوداني
الحالي دكتور
هي وضحت من خلال مؤتمر وزراء الخارجيه
العرب خلال الايام الماضيه القليله
وبالتالي التعويل كبير جدا على مؤتمر
القمه عندما يعني يلتئم الشمل بشكل كامل
لانه اساسا بدات قضيه التعامل مع السودان
والتعاطف معه وعلى راس الاشياء هو يقرار
عدم التدخل في شؤون السودان من اي طرف من
الاطراف طبعا الذي يتم الان بين امريكا
والمبلغ العربيه السعوديه ليست التدخل في
شؤون السودان وانما رعايه
لمؤتمر يمكن ان يرى بالصدوع ويضع لبنات
للحل الختامي في المرحله القادمه ان شاء
الله الكثير يا دكتور يتساءلون اليوم عن
دور الاتحاد الافريقي وكان له دور ايجابي
في حل كثير من القضايا العالقه والازمات
الداخليه الافريقيه الافريقيه لكن في
الازمه السودانيه هناك من ينظر بان
الاتحاد الافريقي قد تراجع دوره كثيرا
خصوصا في السودان هل تتفق دكتور مع هذا
الراي
انا اتفق مع هذا الراي ولكن اعلم السبب
السبب هو انه طبعا الاتحاد الافريقي من
يوم خمسه وعشرين اكتوبر 2021
بدا له يعني راي سالب في المسار العام في
السودان لانه هو اعتبر ما قام به الفريق
البرهان رئيس مجلس السياده اعتبره انقلابا
عسكريا ولوائح الاتحاد الافريقي طبعا لا
تقبل الانقلابات العسكريه ولذلك جمدت
عضويه السودان
وابتعدوا رغم ان موسى فكي يعني ظل على
تواصل مع كثير من الاطراف السودانيه لكن
كانت دور سلبي شيء اخر ما حصل في جبهه
التجراي في اثيوبيا تجاره للسودان يعني
الاتحاد الافريقي كان يرى انه
يعني اثارها السلبيه على السودان تجعل
موقفه فيه كثير من الحرج وبالتالي تراجع
الدور ثم ينري الاتحاد الافريقي نفسه
الياته لحل المشاكل الى حق كبير التراجعت
في القرن الافريقي وفي قضيه الصومال
وفي قضيه
الكونغو وفي مشاكل جنوب السودان يعني
عليهم المشاكل بشكل كبير وبالتالي هناك
يعني ربما تراجع ملحوظ لدوره كما تقول
دكتور شكرا جزيلا لك من ابها انضم الينا
الساده الاعلام في جامعه الملك خالد
الدكتور عوض ابراهيم عوض شكرا جزيلا لك
يستمر مركز الملك سلمان لغاته بتسير الجسر
الجوي الاغاثيلي اليوم الثالث على التوالي
حيث وصل عدد الطائرات التي غادرت الى
بورتسودان خمسه طائرات في غضون ثلاثه ايام
حملت على متنها مساعدات غذائيه ودوائيه
وايوائيه
في ثالث يوم بعد تسيير الجسر الجوي لغ
السعودي لمساعده الشعب السوداني تستعد هذه
الطائره الرابعه لمغادره مطار الملك خالد
الدولي وتحمل على متنها عشره اطنان من
المساعدات الغذائيه والدوائيه والطبيه تم
وضع هذه المساعدات مباشره بهذه الطائره
العسكريه سي وان تيرتي من التي تقودها
القوات المسلحه السعوديه مباشره ستهبط الى
مطار بورت السودان لتفريغ هذه الشحنه
مباشره عبر متعاهدين محليين وكذلك منظمات
محليه تعمل مع مركز الملك سلمان على توزيع
هذه المساعدات مباشره في الداخل السوداني
منذ بدء هذا الجسر الجوي بلغ مجموع هذه
الطائرات او الطائرات العسكريه التي تحمل
مساعدات خمسه طائرات عسكريه حملت على
متنها 50 طنا من المساعدات الغذائيه
والدوائيه والطبيه بالاضافه الى بعض
المساعدات الخاصه التي تم ارسالها عبر هذه
الطائرات ليتم تفريغها مباشره في مطار
بورتسودان في المناطق الواقعه ما بين
بورتسودان والخرطوم وتحديدا في المناطق
التي تم تحديدها في مناطق النزوح بالدرجه
الاولى النزوح الداخلي الذين يبلغ عددهم
ما يقرب 300 الف الى 400 الف نازح في هذه
المناطق بعد ذلك سيتم العمل على ادخال هذه
المساعدات الى مناطق النزاع وتحديدا في
الخرطوم والمناطق التي تتواجد فيها
اشتباكات مسلحه ولكن حين الاتفاق مع
الاطراف اطراف الصراع بشكل مباشر على
ادخال هذه المساعدات ووضع مسارات امنه
للدخول هذه المساعدات من مركز الملك سلمان
وايضا المنظمات الاغاثيه الدوليه العامله
بالداخل
عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه الرياض
ونتابع واياكم هذه الصور
مشاهدينا من باكستان اذا المحكمه العليا
في باكستان قضت بالافراج عن عمران خان
ومثوله غدا امام محكمه اسلام اباد هذا ما
نقله مراسل العربيه
عمران كان قد قال للمحكمه العليا بانه تم
اختطافه من محكمه اسلام اباد وتعرض ايضا
للضرب هذا
والمحكمه العليا ايضا في باكستان قالت بان
اعتقال عمر خان عمران خان عفوا لم يكن
قانونيا هذه صور متابعه واياكم من العاصمه
الباكستانيه اسلام اباد اذن لمتابعه هذه
الاخبار العاجله والتي تريدنا من العاصمه
الباكستانيه اسلام اباد ونحن نعلم بان
رئيس الوزراء السابق الباكستاني عمران خان
قد او القبض عليه يوم امس
بعده وجهت اليه ايضا عده تهم من قبل
المحكمه كذلك ايضا في اسلام مبادرهم غسيل
اموال وفساد ايضا كذلك
لحقه اليوم عدد من طبعا القيادات في حزب
العمران خان منهم وزير الخارجيه السابق
قريشي والذي وجهت اليه ايضا هو الاخر تهم
الفساد من استلام عربيه عبد الرحمن
المزيني عبد الرحمن مرحبا بكم معي في نشاط
الرابعه من الرياض ما الذي يحدث الان كيف
علقت المحكمه العليا في باكستان على
اعتقال عمران خان
بالفعل الفريق القانوني لرئيس وزراء
السابق عمران خان كان قد تقدم
بالتماس امام المحكمه العليا الدستوريه
المحكمه العليا الدستوريه قبلت هذا
الالتماس وشكلت هيئه قضائيه مكونه من
ثلاثه قضاه برئاسه كبير قضاه باكستان عمر
عطا بنديال
المحكمه وبعد المداولات القضيه والاستماع
الى فريق الادعاء وفريق الدفاع عن عمران
خان اعتبرت ان ما جرى في يوم التاسع من
هذا الشهر لم نال من هيبه
القضاء والعداله وان الطريقه التي اعتقل
فيها عمران خان لم تكن طريقه لم تكن طريقه
مناسبه وان القرار الذي اتخذته محكمه
استنابات العليا قرار لكن
وطالبت بالافراج الفوري عن رئيس الوزراء
السابق عمران خان ودعته
الاصول او الرجوع الى محكمه اسلام اباد
العليا ربما اليوم غد ربما بامكانه ان
يتقدم امامها بطلب الحصول على كفاله من
اعتقال في القضيه التي تم اعتقاله على
خلفيتها وهي تتعلق بقضيه فساد بالاستحواذ
على اموال واراضي للدوله بطريقه غير شرعيه
هناك حاله من الابتهاج لدى انصار رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان لكن في المقابل
الحكومه استبقت الاعلان او قرار المحكمه
العليا الدستوريه
بالتساؤل حول ما اذا كان القضاء
سيمنح رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني رعايه خاصه
وتساءلت وزيره الاعلام مريم اورنج زيب كيف
لشخص
حمل انصاره السلاح ضد
رجال الامن
وهددوا الامن العام كيف يمكن الافراج عنه
بهذه السرعه ودون
اكمال الاجراءات التحقيق معه في القضايا
المرفوعه ضدها اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل
هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل التي اوردتها لنا
بانتظار ايضا معلومات اكثر في سياق
النشراتنا القادمه من اسلام مباد مراسل
العربيه عبد الرحمن المزيني شكرا جزيلا لك
ونبقى في الرياض ينضم الينا من هناك مراسل
عربيه عبد المحسن الحربي عبد المحسن مساء
الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض لازال الجسر الجوي يعني يواصل
ارسال مواد غذائيه وايوائيه ايضا طبيه
كذلك الى السودان كيف هي الصوره اليوم
لهذا الجسر الجوي
نعم بالفعل نايف يتواصل هذا الجسر في
يومها الثالث حيث يتم ارسال طائرات يوم
الامس كان هنالك طائره محمله بعشره اطنان
من المساعدات المختلفه بالاضافه الى
طائرتين اليوم في مطار الملك خالد الدولي
وتحديدا في منطقه الشحن يتم ارسال عبرها
عشره اطنان اليوم تم ارسال 20 طن في هذه
الطائره في خلفيه هنالك عشره اطنان تم
وضعها
ليتم ارسالها مباشره والمساعدات هي
مساعدات غذائيه وايوائيه والطبيه بالدرجه
الاولى يتم ارسالها عبر رفيق مختص يشرف
على عمليه ارسال هذه المساعدات من مطار
الملك خالد الدوليه عبر طائره سي وانت
التابع للقوات المسلحه السعوديه التي تقوم
بارسال هذه المساعدات مباشره الى مطار
بورتسودان حيث هنالك في استقبالها فريق
مختص من مركز الملك سلمان الذي ذهب في
اليوم الاول للجسر الجوي
صديقاتي السعودي في مطار بورتسودان وعملها
على تنظيم وتسهيل دخول هذه المساعدات
مباشره الى داخل مطار بورتسودان ومن ثم
التعاون مع المنظمات السودانيه المحليه
الاغاثيه الانسانيه العامله هناك
لتسهيل توزيعها بشكل مباشر وتوزيعها على
المحتاجين والمستفيدين منها بالدرجه
الاولى في الحقيقه نايف هنالك العديد من
منصات او العديد من المواقع التي تم
تحديدها
لتوزيع هذه المساعدات بشكل مباشر بالدرجه
الاولى مركز الملك سلمان سيوزع هذه
المساعدات على المناطق
المتضرره وتحديدا التي يتواجد بها نازحين
اكثر نظرا لان الاوضاع الامنيه بداخل
المدن الكبرى لم يتم تحديد حتى الان
مسارات امنه لدخول مثلا على سبيل المثال
الخرطوم التي يتواجد بها هناك احتياجات
كبرى تتواجد بها على على المثال في القطاع
الطبي والقطاع ايضا الغذائي وغيرها من
احتياجات الاخرى في الخرطوم ولكن هذه
المساعدات تذهب مباشره الى النازحين الذين
يبلغ عددهم ما يقارب 300 الى 400 الف وهم
يتزايدون باستمرار لذلك نشاهد ان المركز
الملك سلمان عبر هذا الجسر لغاته ارسله
مندوبي على الارض ليقوموا بعمليه الدراسه
المتواصله لعمليه الاحتياجات وفيما اذا
كان هنالك احتياجات اخرى سيتم ارسالها عبر
الطائرات المتواصله يوميا في مطار الملك
خالد الدولي حيث وصلت الان بعد الطائرات
الى خمسه طائرات ارسلت 50 طنا من مساعدات
مساعدات هذه الطائره الخامسه التي تستعد
للاقلاع مباشره والذهاب الى مطر بورتسودان
بالاضافه الى الطائرات الاخرى التي يتم
الاستعداد لارسالها خلال الايام القادمه
بالاضافه لذلك تتواصل عمليه التبرع
المباشر عبر المنصه التي تم استحداثها من
قبل منصه من قبل الملك سلمان وتحديدا
ايقونه مساعده الشعب السوداني عبر التبرع
المباشر التي وصلت عدد عمليات التبرع فيها
الى اكثر من 17 الف عمليه تبرع من 17 الف
شخص او وصلت عدد الاموال التي تم التبرع
فيها ثلاثه مليون ونصف المليون
في خلال هذا اليوم بالاضافه الى المبلغ
الذي تم تخصيصه نايف في بدايه انطلاق هذه
هذا الجسر وتحديدا نتحدث عن 100 مليون
دولار تم تخسيسها من قبل مركز الملك سلمان
بالاضافه الى فتح المجال للمواطنين
والمقيمين في السعوديه للمساهمه في هذه
العمليه الاغاثيه العاجله لمساعده الشعب
السوداني والنازحين في مختلف مناطق
السودان وبالاضافه وبالاضافه الى خارج
السودان اشكرك جزيل الشكر من الرياض مراسل
العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل
بدات الجوازات السعوديه اجراءات تمديد مده
الاقامه للتاشيرات المعتمرين السودانيين
وذلك لجميع من تصعب عودتهم الى بلادهم في
ظل الازمه الحاليه كما اعلنت الجوازات في
بيانها عن اطلاق خدمه استضافه المعتمرين
السودانيين على منصه ابشر من قبل معارفهم
من المقيمين في السعوديه او المواطنين
وتحويل تاشيره العمره الى تاشيره زياره
عائليه او شخصيه مع امكانيه تعديل اسم
المستضيف في سجل المعتمرين واعفائهم من
الرسوم الماليه للمره الاولى
ويلتحق بنا المتحدث الرسمي باسم مديريه
العملي الجوازات الرائد ناصر العتيبي رائد
ناصر اهلا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نريد معلومات اكثر عن ما تغير في
التعامل مع من بقي من يعني مواطني جمهوريه
السودان في المملكه العربيه السعوديه منذ
فتره العمره وحتى اليوم بسبب الاوضاع في
السودان
دعني ارحب بك اخوي نايف وجميع المشاهدين
قناه العربي الكرام حقيقه كما ذكرت انه
امتدادا للدعم السخي من حكومه خادم
الحرمين الشريفين وسمو سيدي ولي العهد
حفظهم الله وامتداد لما كانت تقدم ويقدم
حتى اللحظه
من جهود وخدمات للجمهوريه السودان
ومواطنين ايضا ورعايه الدول الصديقه
والشقيقه سواء كان في عمليات الاجلاء التي
لا تزال مستمره عبر المنافذ البريه
البحريه والجويه المخصصه لذلك وايضا عبر
الخدمات الالكترونيه والمساعدات التي تقدم
لهم حيث اعلن مؤخرا اليوم تحديدا
وايفات الاتجاهات التوجيهات الكريمه بدات
المديريه العامه للجوازات في اجراءات
تمديد الاقامه
لتاشيرات المعتبرين السودانيين في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والذين يصعب عليهم
العوده لبلادهم بسبب الظروف الراهنه هذه
الخدمات اطلقت في منصه ابشر
سعاده الرائد
هذه الخدمات الاجرائيه في المديريه العمل
الجوازات ايضا اطلق على منصه ابشر دعم
استضافه المعتمرين السودانيين في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
للسودانيين المقيمين اصلا في السعوديه
ويرغبون باستضافه احد اقاربهم او معارفهم
الذين علقوا في المملكه ولم يستطيع
خدمه استضافه المعتمرين السودانيين فقط
خاصه بالمعتمرين الاستضافه تكون من قبل
الاقارب او ذويهم او المقيمين في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه او حتى تشمل المواطنين
السعوديين لاستضافه هؤلاء حسب الشروط
المطبقه والمعلنه في منصه ابشر كيف يمكن
السودانيين ايضا ان يستبدلوا التاشيره
الموجوده لديهم التي كانت تاشيره
يعني عمره كيف يستبدلونها الى تاشيره
الزياره او الاقامه ايضا حتى كذلك وهل
هناك نطاق معين او وقت معين لهذه التاشيره
هو يتم تحويل تاشيره العمره الى تاشيره
زياره سواء كانت زياره عائليه او زياره
شخصيه حسب اختيار وتحديد المستفيد نفسه
تتم من خلال دخول المستضيف سواء كان مواطن
او مقيم الى منصه حسابه الشخصي على منصه
ابشر واتباع الخطوات والاجراءات اللازمه
وبعد ذلك الدخول الى خدماتي ثم اختيار
ايقونه الجوازات وتقديم خدمه او تقديم
الطلب عن طريق خدمه التواصل وسديد
التاشيرات الزيارات ثم الدخول الى
استضافه المعتمرين السودانيين على منصه
ابشر والتقييد بالشروط الوارده في المنصه
وتقديم الطلب الذي يتم دراسته من قبل
الموظف في الجوازات خلال مده لا تجاوز 48
ساعه يتم خلالها معالجه الطلب وارسال
رساله نصيه للمستفيد على جوال هاتفين
المدون في منصه ابشر هل هم معفنين من
الرسوم الماليه على هذه التاشيرات
بكل تاكيد الرسوم للمره الاولى
مجانيه كل المتحدث الرسمي باسم المدير
العمل للجوازات الرائد ناصر العتيبي شكرا
لك
السفير السعوديه لدى اليمن محمد الجابر ان
الحكومه والحوثيين ابدايا جديه للسلام لكن
من المستحيل التنبؤ بموعد اجراء محادثات
مباشره اضاف الجابر ان هناك تفاؤلا تجاه
ايجاد مخرج في اسرع وقت ممكن واشار الى ان
السعوديه تعتبر نفسها اكثر من وسيط يحاول
تسهيل اتفاق بين الحكومه والحوثيين
حتى وزراء خارجيه كل من مصر والاردن
وفرنسا والمانيا لانهاء اعمال العنف بين
اسرائيل وغزه وصرحت وزيره خارجيه المانيا
انلينا بيربوك انه يجب وقف الدماء على
الفور وادان وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح
شكري الاعمال العدائيه كما اضاف نظيره
الاردني ايمن الصفدي انه يجب استعاده
السلام بين الطرفين
اكد وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري ان
الجهود للتهدئه بين اسرائيل والفلسطينيين
مستمره لكنها لم تؤتي نتائجها المرجوه حتى
الان وطلب شكر المجتمع الدولي التدخل لوقف
ما يتعرض له الشعب الفلسطيني
انما نطالب المجتمع الدولي الذي يقع على
عاتقه ايضا مسؤوليه السياسيه وقانونيه
وانسانيه
فيما الت اليه الاوضاع الشعب الفلسطيني
بان يبدي ذات الحماسه والتصميم لمعالجه
تلك القضيه العادله كما ابداها بالنسبه
للازمات القائمه الاخرى واؤكد ان الجهود
المصريه المستمره في هذا الصدر بما في ذلك
في سياق الاحداث الاخيره بخطاع غزه سواء
اعترف الى النزاع او المجتمع الدولي من
اجل التهدئه وسعيا لاستئناف العمليه
السياسيه
هذا ورغم ما نبذله من جهود مدنيه الا ان
تلك الجهود ما زالت لم تؤتي ثمارها
ونتائجها المرجوه
اكد وزير الخارجيه الاردنيه من الصفه
ضروره التحرك الجماعي لوقف الاعتداء على
غزه قائلا خلال مشاركته في قمه ميونخ في
المانيا ان امن الاسرائيليين من امن
الفلسطينيين ولا سلامه لطرف دون الاخر
نحتاج ان نتحرك جميعا لوقف الاعتداء
الاسرائيلي على غزه ووقف العنف الذي سببه
ذلك استعاده الهدوء ومن ثم اطلاق افق
سياسي يعيد اطلاق عمليه سلميه جاده وفاعله
تاخذنا باتجاه تحقيق حل الدولتين السلام
حق للجميع الامن حق للجميع امنوا اسرائيل
لن يتحقق من دون ان يحصل الفلسطينيون على
امنهم
الرابعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل ايضا
منظومه او صندوق الموارد البشريه السعوديه
يعلن عن رفع قيمه دعم حضانه اطفال
الموظفات
حياكم الله من جديد وقع وزير البيئه
والمياه والزراعه السعوديه المهندس عبد
الرحمن الفضي اتفاقيه شراء طائرات لصالح
البرنامج الاستمطار السحب حيث يهدف
المشروع الى بناء القدرات الداخليه ونقل
وتوطين المعرفه واستدامه الاعمال ورفع
مستوى تغطيه وكفاءه عمليات الاستمطار كما
ان المشروع يعمل على خط التكاليف المصاحبه
لتشغيل الطائرات من خلال توفير طائرات
خاصه
ومجهزه ايضا كذلك
بكافه تقنيات الاستمطار
المستهدف اليوم هي المنطقه الوسطى الرياض
وحائل القصيم والمنطقه الجنوبيه الغربيه
عسير والباحه ومرتفعات مكه المكرمه لكن مع
وجود الابحاث باذن الله تعالى سوف يكون
هناك
امتداد لهذه العمليات على مناطق استوجب او
تستدعي مننا عمليات استمطار صناعي لزياده
الهاطل المطري في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الهدف اليوم الطائرات المملكه
لكل مناطق المملكه باذن الله تعالى متى ما
دعت الحاجه والدراسات الى اللي هي وجود
حاجه للاستمرار وايضا وجود جدوى للاستمرار
على هذه المناطق
معي هنا في الاستوديو المدير التنفيذي
للبرنامج الاقليمي للاستمرار في السعوديه
ايمن البارصي دائما حياك الله
من الرياض وخلينا نعرف اولا تفاصيل هذه
الاتفاقيه لشراء خمس طائرات لصالح وزاره
البيئه والمياه وكلها طبعا في اطار
استمطار السحب صحيح تم بحمد الله توقيع
اتفاقيه شراء خمس طائرات تعتبر الاحدث على
مستوى العالم والمملكه العربيه السعوديه
اليوم هي اول دوله على مستوى العالم
تتمتلك الطراز الحديث من طائرات الاستمطار
اربع طائرات مخصصه لتنفيذ عمليات
الاستمطار وطائره مخصصه لعمليات الابحاث
نستهدف من خلال الاتفاقيه الى رفع الكفاءه
التشغيليه لعمليات الاستمطار بالاضافه الى
نقل وتوطين التقنيات في هذا المجال الطائر
الخامس هي طائره ابحاث تتعلق بالاستمرار
مش دراسه المناخ بشكل كامل يعني صحيح هذه
الطائر المخصصه فيها احدث التقنيات اليوم
هي عباره عن مختبر على طائره يستهدف جمع
عينات مخصصه السحر بهدف دراستها ورفع
المستوى التشغيلي وكفاءه التشغيل العمليات
اليوم انتم وصلتوا لمرحله
الثالثه تقريبا
على الرابعه وش ابرز النتائج اللي تحققت
من الاستمطار برنامج الاستمطار الحمد لله
اليوم احنا بعد ما اتمنى المرحله الثالثه
احنا نتكلم اليوم على تنفيذ 190 مهمه او
رحله استمراريه تجاوز
625 ساعه طيران التقديرات الاوليه للهاطل
المطري تتجاوز الثلاثه مليار متر مكعب على
المنطقتين سواء كان المنطقه الوسطى
والمنطقه الجنوبيه وبالتالي هذا
يعني هو هذا الرقم اساسي لنجاح هذه
التجارب اكيد اليوم احنا نستهدف
بالاستمرار الى زياده الهاطل المطري
وبالتالي احنا اليوم نعمل على تقييم
التجربه بشكل عام كل البيانات هذه راحتك
تجميعها ومشاركتها نجاح المراحل اليوم
احنا في عمل مشترك ما بين قطاع الابحاث
والمراكز العالميه بحيث انه نشاركهم
المعلومات اللي اليوم احنا تحصلنا عليها
ومن خلالهم راح يتم تقييم التجربه هذه
ويعطون النساء لانه انا قريت في في البحث
عن هالبرنامج انه نسبه النجاح وصلت 97%
وهذا رقم كبير يعني احنا نتكلم على
الكفاءه التشغيليه فتنفيذ عمليات
الاستمرار مش البرنامج كامل يعني صحيح طيب
وين المناطق اللي ركزتوا عليها في المرحله
الثالثه تحديدا المرحله الثالثه كانت خاصه
بالمنطقه الوسطى لمنطقه الرياض والقصيم
وحايل وش النتائج اللي خرجتوا فيها جزء من
المجموع الهاطل المطري كان مخصص للمنطقه
الوسطى ما شاء الله تبارك الله كان موسم
ناجح خلينا نقول والكفاءه التشغيليه
تجاوزت 97% خلال مرحله الثالثه وبالتالي
هذا هو ما دفعكم
او دفع الوزاره لهذا الاتفاقيه شراء
طائرات اكثر لان التجارب نجحت اكيد هذا
جزء منها ممتاز انتم كان عندكم 190 مهمه
كما ذكرت قبل قليل وين ركزت اغلبها المهام
تقريبا التوزيع نتكلم 30 الى 40% المنطقه
الوسطى والنسبه الاكبر للمنطقه الجنوبيه
بما انه كانت الفتره الاطول للمنطقه
الجنوبيه والمرحله الرابعه اليوم راح تكون
على المنطقه اللي حطوا في تغيير وفي
المناطق الجنوبيه انا اتكلم على المناطق
اللي تشهد دائما هطول الامطار وبشكل يمكن
لا ينقطع خلال اشهر معينه من السنه
لاحظتوا زياده في كميات الامطار فيها صحيح
من خلال شبكه الرصد اللي يمتلكها المركز
الوطني للارصاد تم تسجيل جميع الكميات هذه
الامطار واليوم نحن في حيز عمل مقارنات
خلينا نسميها على خلال طوال الفترات بحيث
انه تعطي معلومه واضحه هل كان هذا بسبب
خلينا نقول السجلات الحاليه اليوم نتكلم
عنه هو اختلاف موسمي من موسم الاخر وهذا
هو سؤال مهم وما يحصل في المناخ والتغيرات
اساسا اللي حاصله فبالتالي
اللي يتابع يعني كميات الامطار في
هالمناطق زادت بشكل كبير حتى المره
الاخيره تقريبا من شهر في يتكلموا على
انها الابطال لم تحدث منذ عشرات السنين
صحيح فبالتالي لها علاقه بالبرنامج اليوم
البرنامج ياخذ جزء حيز من المعادله خلينا
نقول المناخيه باضافته للمواد هذه وتحفيز
السحب وزياده الهطل المطري بس يبقى السؤال
اليوم انه احنا في مراكز بحثيه متخصصه
لازم يكون
الملف البحثي متكامل بحيث انه نعطي جواب
شافي في هذا المجال ان شاء الله بالتوفيق
لكم ان شاء الله
مدير التنفيذي للبرنامج الاقليمي
للاستمرار في السعوديه سيد ايمن شكرا لك
شكرا
برنامج استمطار السحب
انهى ثلاث مراحل
ويستعد لاطلاق المرحله الرابعه
97% نسبه نجاح اعمال البرنامج
و190 مهمه استمطار حتى الان استخدام ثلاثه
الاف واربعمائه وخمس شعلات استمطار هطوله
ثلاثه مليارات مليون متر مكعب على المناطق
المستهدفه
تمكنت هيئه الزكاه والضريبه والجمارك في
منفذ الحديث من احباط محاوله تهريب كميه
من حبوب الكبتاجون حيث بلغ عددها اكثر من
460 الف حبه عثر عليها مخباه في شاحنه
وردت الى السعوديه عبر المنفذ نتابع
[موسيقى]
اطلق صندوق تنميه الموارد البشريه هدف
تحسينات على منتج دعم ضيافه الاطفال القره
وذلك من خلال تطوير الاليه الخاصه بالمنتج
حيث تضمنت التحسينات الجديده تغطيه 50% من
التكلفه الشهريه على ان لا يتجاوز مبلغ
الدعم 1600 ريال لكل طفل بالاضافه لمده
الدعم المفتوحي وغير المحدد بعدد سنوات
معينه بخلاف ما كان سابقا ونصت التحسينات
ايضا لقره على عدم وجود احد اعلى لعدد
الاطفال للاستفاده
لاستفاده الموظفه من الدعم
الرابعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل ايضا
تضم مناطق وعلامات تجاريه فاخره منطقه
فياريال تبدا اليوم استقبال الزوار
حياكم الله من جديد تفتتحوا اليوم في
الرياض المنطقه الترفيهيه الاحدث فياريال
حيث تعد احد ابهى المناطق الترفيهيه التي
تحتضنها العاصمه ذلك كلمات تحتويه من ارقى
العلامات التجاريه العالميه والمحليه
واشهر فنادق الخمسه نجوم وصلاه السينما
الفاخره والعديد من المطاعم والمقاهي
المميزه كما شيدت فيا رياض شيودت على
الطراز السلماني والذي يتوافق مع الهويه
المحليه لمنطقه الرياض
شكرا زياد وصلت شمس خلال هذه الايام في
منتصف المسافه بين مدارس سرطان وخط
الاستواء متجهه الى مدار السرطان التفاصيل
في تقويم معهد الزهق
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تطوف الارض حول الشمس في رحله ثانويه
مقدارها 3065 يوما تقريبا وبناء على ذلك
فان مكان وزمان شروق وغروب الشمس يتغير
بشكل يومي فتتعامد الشمس على مدار سرطان
عند وصولها الى اقصى ميل لها ناحيه الشمال
اطول يوما بسنه وتتعامد على مدار الجدي
عند وصولها الى اقصى ميل لها ناحيه الجنوب
اطول ليله بالسنه وبينهما تتعامد على خط
الاستواء يتساوى في طول الليل مع النهار
وبعد اربعين يوما تتعامد الشمس على مدار
السرطان ومدار السرطان يمر على سلطنه عمان
والامارات والسعوديه وحين ذاك سنعيش اطول
نهر واقصر ليالي السنه الا ليت النهار
يعود فان الصبح ياتي بالهموم حوائج لا
تطيق لها قضاء ولا ردا وردان الغريمي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والشمس الان وصلت منتصف المسافه بين خط
الاستواء ومدار السرطان وفي اثناء مسيرها
تمر على اليمن وجنوب السعوديه على شكل
تعامد بمعنى ان ظل الزوال سيختفي على
اليمن وجنوب السعوديه وين على عسير وابهى
والباحث وهذا يكون مرتين بسنه والشمس
طالعه فوق مثل هالايام والشمس نازله تحت
بعد شهرين تقريبا الظل يرقب في الدروب
خطايا واناه زادت عن حدودي انايا ظل انا
والامنيات حقيقتي ابكي ويبحث عن صداه
بكايه
[موسيقى]
الرابعه بابرز عناوينها
مصادر دبلوماسيه تكشف للعربيه عن توصل
الاطراف السودانيه لاتفاق مبدئي خلال
محادثات جده
الجوازات السعوديه تمدد اقامه تاشيرات
المعتمرين السودانيين وتطلق خدمه
الاستضافتهم
هيئه الصناعات العسكريه السعوديه تعلن عن
تجاوز نسبه توطين القطاع الثلاثه عشر في
المئه
الجمارك السعوديه تعلن احباط محاوله تهريب
نحو نصف مليون حبه مخدره عبر منفذ الحديث
وزاره البيئه السعوديه تعلن عن اتفاقيه
لشراء خمس طائرات الاستمطار السحب
والدراسات للمناخ
نهايه الرابعه شكرا لكم الى اللقاء
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات